There were a few things I didn't get to finish last time on talking about a
particularly gene transfer in,
um,
in,
uh,
mammals.
And I want to finish with that and then start on the topic for this week,
which is,
uh,
an introduction to cellular physiology and,
in particular cell culture technology or how you culture cells outside the body.
And,
um,
so this is the slide that I left on,
uh,
last time.
Um,
and the idea here was to use plasmids,
which I talked about,
uh,
last Thursday to introduce genes into animals.
And here the,
uh,
the,
the plasma is directly injected into the cell and the cell is a,
uh,
a fertilized egg.
And so you take a fertilized egg and you directly inject plasma DNA into the
pronucleus into one of the pronucleus pronuclei and hear this solves a major
problem,
which I'm going to talk about just at the beginning of class here in a slide or
two,
is,
uh,
how to get DNA into cells.
And we talked last week or the week before about the plasma membrane and
something about the chemistry of the plasma membrane,
lipid biolayer.
Uh,
that stable in water because it's arranged in such a way that the hydrophilic
parts of the lipid molecules are exposed to both the outer and the inner surface
of the cell.
But there's lipid chains in between,
right?
So cell membranes are lipid rich layers that can exist in water.
And because of that,
they're barriers,
right?
They separate the inside of the cell from the outside of itself and only certain
kinds of molecules can pass through a cell membrane.
It has to be small and it has to be lipid soluble in order for it to pass
through a through a cell membrane.
Well,
plasma DNA is neither of those.
It's very water soluble and it's a big molecule,
a very big molecule.
And so it can't naturally get in,
decide sells on its own.
And we talked about this a little bit in section last week.
When you eat vegetables or meat,
you're eating a lot of DNA,
but that doesn't enter the cells of your body.
All right?
Because of the barrier properties of cell membranes.
So to get genes and gene transfer vectors into cells is a problem here.
The problem is solved by injecting it directly into the cell shown here.
And then,
uh,
that's one,
that's one issue with gene delivery.
The second issue is that the gene vector,
in this case,
the plasmid has to be compatible with the cells that you're trying to express
the gene in.
And that means that the cells have to be able to replicate the DNA on the
plasmid.
So in order to make many more copies of it,
so it has to have an origin of replication,
which we talked about last time,
which is compatible with the cells.
And it also has to have a promoter for the gene that the cells can recognize.
And in this case,
the promoter,
which is a sequence of DNA that is positioned right in front of the gene of
interest.
The promoter is the Beta lactoglobulin promoter in this case,
and Beta lactoglobulin as a milk protein.
So you're taking advantage of a promoter system or a gene activation system that
this species knows about because adult animals can make milk
and when they make milk,
they,
uh,
they have the signals for turning on the Beta lactoglobulin promoter.
And expressing the gene of interest.
Okay.
So both of those things have to be correct,
right?
You have to be able to get the DNA into the cell has to be incorporated into a
vector of some sort and the vector has to be compatible with the species and the
cells that you've provided the DNA to.
So in this case,
if everything goes right,
you inject the DNA into the pro nucleus,
you implant this fertilized egg into a foster mother.
Uh,
the mother gives birth to an offspring,
it develops and when it develops,
this foreign DNA is in the offspring.
And when the,
when this,
uh,
animal makes milk,
it makes all the normal milk proteins,
but it also activates your gene of interest as well.
And so you could collect your gene of interest in the milk.
Right?
That makes sense.
This,
this concept of introducing foreign genes,
genes that are made of recombinant DNA into animals using this kind of technique
is widely used in biomedical research.
And one of the ways that it's used is to take the fertilized egg from an animal,
let's say a mouse.
Usually it's a mouse.
And inject in a vector that contains a gene that,
uh,
that is involved in human disease of some sort,
right?
So one of the big problems with studying human diseases is that you can study
how they occur in people,
but there's only a limited amount that you can learn from people.
You know,
if animals get a similar disease,
then you can learn about that disease progression in much more detail in the
animal,
right?
So,
but unfortunately there aren't good animal models for many of the diseases that
we'd like to study.
Alzheimer's disease is a good one,
you know,
millions of affected by Alzheimer's disease.
Other species don't get Alzheimer's disease,
right?
And,
but you can produce animals that have a disease that's similar in some ways to
Alzheimer's disease by taking the genes that are involved in Alzheimer's and
introducing them into mice,
for example.
And you do that by expressing the genes in the mice in,
in the way that I described on the last slide.
And it's shown a little bit more detail on this slide.
And those animals that you produce are called transgenic animals because they're
expressing usually at high levels a trans gene or a gene that's not normally
present in their species.
Well,
how would you accomplish this kind of,
uh,
how would you accomplish gene transfer in adult humans?
Right.
Those two examples I just gave you one headed directly inject,
um,
a,
uh,
a gene containing vector into the pro nucleus of a fertilized egg.
Um,
and you don't have that opportunity and adults,
you already have an adult organism and you'd like to get the gene transferred.
Well,
before we talk about how to do it,
and we don't have perfect ways to do it yet,
but I'll describe some of the ways that are used.
I want to talk just briefly on this slide about what the goals for gene therapy
might be.
And there's a variety of different ways to think about using gene therapy and
they're,
they're illustrated in this picture.
Um,
one way is to replace a gene that's defective in,
uh,
disease.
And uh,
so usually this is a disease that's caused by a defect in a single gene.
So we talked about sickle cell anemia last time.
That's an example.
Another example is cystic fibrosis and cystic fibrosis is a disease that affects
many organ systems,
but particularly the lung and you get cystic fibrosis because one protein that's
made by your lung epithelium is not expressed properly.
You're able to make the protein but the protein doesn't function properly.
And so what you could potentially treat cystic fibrosis by providing the correct
gene and providing it to all the cells of the lung epithelium.
Um,
so because of this,
because cystic fibrosis is a disease that's caused by a single gene defect,
uh,
there's been great interest in trying to treat cystic fibrosis with gene
therapy.
And the idea would be to try to give,
usually in the lungs,
people have thought about this because that's where the main manifestations of
the disease occur.
And introduce a gene vector into the lungs,
perhaps by having a patient inhale it or by somehow instilling it into the lungs
in such a way that the,
these gene vectors get taken up by cells and the gene gets expressed throughout
the,
the lung.
And so this might be a plasmid,
it might be a plasmid that contains a promoter that works in lung cells and that
has the cystic fibrosis gene.
Well now how would you get the gene into the cells here?
But one way you can get it is by mixing the gene with lipids,
with lipid molecules and special lipids that do this are called cat ionic
lipids,
their lipids.
But they also have a charged portion,
a positively charged portion,
which interacts with DNA.
And so your form DNA,
lipid complexes.
And because the DNA is complex with lipids,
it's more soluble and membranes and more likely to enter cells.
So that's one way to do it.
And we'll talk about another ways in just a minute.
But you get,
the idea here is to deliver the gene that you're interested in directly to the
tissue where it's being used.
And in this case,
the idea is to introduce a gene that's missing.
Now,
in other cases you might want to introduce a gene that's not even normally
present in people.
And you're doing that because you want to treat disease in a different way.
And one way that that's done is by introducing genes into cancer cells,
genes that aren't normally expressed in any mammalian cell,
but that will cause the cancer cell to die.
And this example here,
the idea is to introduce a gene into tumors,
cells of a tumor,
and it's a gene that allows you to deliver a drug that's not active,
but the gene causes that active,
that inactive drug to be converted into an active form that kills the cell.
So this is called a suicide gene.
Basically you're introducing this gene into cells that when you give the right,
inactive drug that will cause the cell to make chemicals that kill it,
right?
Does that make sense?
And so this is a way of introducing cyto toxicity or cell killing ability into a
cell.
And that's,
that's been used to treat many kinds of cancers,
particularly cancers of the brain.
The problem is the same.
How do I get the gene that I want into only the cells that I want?
Right?
And you could see that it would be a problem here if the gene that you were
trying to give to the cancer cells also went to normal cells,
right?
That would be a problem.
And this is a common problem in gene therapy.
You would like to get the gene that you're interested in expressed in some
population of cells within the body but not in other cells.
So making gene therapies specific is a key problem and making it work.
So these are two examples.
I just gave you a introducing genes that affect the life of a cell,
either by making it express a protein that it's not making properly.
That's important too.
It's life or by intentionally killing a cell,
by having an express,
a,
a fatal gene.
Uh,
the other examples on the bottom of the slide here are,
uh,
introducing genes that affect neighboring tissues.
And so a one a way to do this might be too,
if you're trying to treat a heart that has disease and usually it's disease in
one of the coronary vessels or the blood vessels that serve the heart,
that provide blood to the heart.
Coronary artery disease is one of the major,
um,
major causes of death in,
in,
uh,
western countries.
Um,
and uh,
it,
it occurs because blood flow gets reduced in that blood vessel,
right?
And so the heart muscle,
which is actively beating all the time,
needs large quantities of oxygen provided by blood,
can't get the blood through the vessel.
So here at concept is to introduce a gene that causes the process of new blood
vessel growth.
If you could introduce that gene,
you'd make the chemical,
in this case,
it's a protein called vascular endothelial growth factor.
The name of the molecule isn't important,
but it's a molecule that stimulates the heart to produce new blood vessels
around it,
right?
So this is introducing a gene.
It's a natural gene,
uh,
but it's not,
it's a natural gene that's found in humans and is actually expressed all over
your body in different levels,
uh,
but you're concentrating it or overexpressing it in one particular region of
tissue in order to have a particular effect,
right?
So you're taking a normal gene in your overexpressing it or expressing it more
abundantly than normal in one particular spot of the body to have an effect
at one.
Last example here is,
um,
that you might want to,
put a,
put a gene in that makes a protein in a tissue that doesn't ordinarily make it
so that that tissue can make large quantities of the protein and serve sort of
as a source of that protein as a drug.
So the example might be insulin,
right?
Your pancreas normally makes insulin.
Diabetics who,
whose pancreas does not function properly,
so don't make enough insulin,
uh,
don't have enough insulin present for normal glucose metabolism so they can't
handle sugars properly.
Uh,
but what if you injected the gene for insulin into their muscle so that their
muscle cells in one particular location started making insulin?
Right?
Then that insulin would accumulating the muscle and to the blood and circulate
all over the body.
And so you'd turn the muscle into an insulin making tissue.
Right.
Okay.
So those are some examples of different strategies for using gene therapy and
people.
Well,
I talked about the pro problem of using plasmids in,
um,
in gene therapy that you,
you,
it's very difficult to get them into cells.
There are other vectors that are very efficient at getting DNA into cells.
Viruses in particular,
are very effective at delivering their viral DNA into cells.
So if you catch a cold,
you get exposed to someone who has,
um,
who has,
uh,
a virus that's causing an upper respiratory infection.
Uh,
they cough near you.
That virus enters your respiratory system,
it infects cells of your respiratory system,
and those viruses replicate.
They basically make many,
many copies of their DNA and they make all of their viral proteins and they
assemble into new viral units.
Right?
Well,
what if you could hijack that virus to carry genes that you want?
Right.
And you could do that by using the techniques we described with,
with uh,
restriction enzymes and [inaudible] to cut and paste the viral
genome so that it contains the,
um,
the gene of interest to you.
So you make a recombinant virus that has all the normal components of the virus
but also has a gene that you want,
right?
And now all you have to do is introduce that virus into an organism and the
virus will do what it naturally does,
which is infect some cells.
Now the other nice thing about viruses is not only are they very efficient,
but most viruses are specific for certain kinds of cells.
The kinds of viruses that we get when we have colds are very good at,
at infecting the respiratory system.
If you get a,
if you get a flu that affects your,
uh,
your intestinal system than those viruses are infecting gut cells.
There's other viruses that infect cells of the brain,
of the kidney,
of the liver.
Hepatitis is a virus that specifically affects the liver.
So viruses are often specific to certain kinds of cells.
And that is also an advantage of using them as gene therapy vehicles because
they will only infect cells that they are,
uh,
that they have an affinity for that they're prone to affect.
Um,
this picture here,
we're going to come back to this later in,
um,
in,
uh,
two weeks when we start talking about vaccines and we're going to talk about how
you make vaccines for viruses.
And so in,
in doing that,
we're going to think about the,
the life cycle of a virus.
A,
this is a life cycle of a particular class of viruses called retroviruses.
Uh,
you know about retroviruses.
The most famous and important one at,
at this time is HIV,
which is a retrovirus.
This shows the,
the,
uh,
greatly magnified compared to the size of a cell because viruses are much,
much smaller than cells,
right?
They might be a hundred nanometers or so in diameter,
whereas a sale is 10 microns or so in diameter.
So these very small particles are able to specifically recognize certain kinds
of cells.
They enter the cell after recognizing they fall apart inside the cell.
They reproduce their DNA or their genetic material using,
using a host mechanisms.
They,
in some cases,
they integrate their DNA into the host chromosome.
That's what a retroviruses do.
And they make a viral proteins because they've made many copies of their genome
and they've made all the proteins that are necessary to,
for a assembly of a new virus than this cell can make many new viruses.
Right?
So that's another advantage of using viruses as a gene therapy vector.
They can reproduce.
And so you only need to give a few of them in order to make many,
many inside the body.
So why,
why,
uh,
why isn't that the solution,
to,
uh,
gene therapy?
If you can genetically engineer viruses like this and viruses have all those
good properties as gene therapy vehicles that I described.
Why isn't this a solution?
Well,
there are problems with viruses as well.
Um,
that,
um,
retroviruses for example,
can only insert,
can only transduce and express their DNA in cells that are dividing.
And so if it's not a cell that's going through division,
you can't use a retrovirus to,
uh,
to express the protein.
Uh,
they integrate their DNA into the host genome when you might not want to make
that kind of a change right in the,
in the cell.
And so these are some problems with retroviruses.
It's because of this.
People have sought other kinds of viruses to use as vectors and one that's
commonly used as an add no virus ad,
no viruses are viruses that give a upper respiratory infections.
They cause colds.
Um,
they can transduce non dividing cells.
So that's a good part.
They can insert genes into non dividing cells and cause those genes to be
expressed.
But a problem with vi with,
with Adeno viruses is that your immune system recognizes them.
And if your immune system recognizes the virus,
then it can attack the virus and eliminated from the body.
Now normally that's a good thing because if you're out in the world and you get
infected with ad,
no virus,
you recover from it,
right?
Your immune system can get rid of it.
But if you're trying to use that virus as a gene delivery vector and your body
gets rid of it,
then the therapy has failed,
right?
It's ended.
And so people have tried to produce viruses that are different ad no viruses,
for example,
that your immune system can't recognize.
But because of this,
because of,
uh,
the natural properties of viruses,
which sometimes are unwanted,
like in retro viruses and,
uh,
and the natural properties of your immune system,
which can cause you to reject viruses,
uh,
we've had,
great problems in making,
uh,
making viruses that are both safe and effective for gene therapy in people.
I,
uh,
talked about,
just not using viruses but using plasma DNA together with the lipids.
And that's another strategy for a gene therapy.
And,
um,
and we'll talk later about other kinds of vehicles,
uh,
when we talk about new methods for delivery of drugs.
Okay.
So that's what I wanted to say.
And finishing up,
um,
in,
in finishing up,
uh,
last week's topic of DNA technology
and what I want to do for the rest of the time,
uh,
today is talk about a little bit about cell physiology,
but I'm not going to say too much,
uh,
for a couple of reasons.
I think most of you know something about the sort of architecture and normal
structure of a,
of a cell and the components within it.
And the chapter chapter five has a good description of that.
For those of you who want a refresher.
So we'll talk a little bit about the principles of a sale or physiology and then
I'll move,
uh,
next time to talking about how you culture cells outside of the body and what
that's useful for.
Okay.
So I,
I used,
I said this sentence in one of the first two classes,
all cells are the same.
And,
um,
and uh,
you know,
that's true.
We talk about cells as being kind of the fundamental unit of humans and other
multicellular organisms.
And why do we talk about them as the fundamental units?
Uh,
because cells on their own are alive.
They can do the things that we associate with life.
They replicate,
they,
uh,
they reproduce,
they,
uh,
they metabolize right,
they can move,
they can grow and they can use nutrients and make wastes.
Um,
and they work cooperatively in order to,
uh,
perform some function.
And,
uh,
this is a picture that I showed you before,
but basically,
um,
uh,
tells you something that you already know that humans are made up of organ
systems,
organs and organ systems.
Those organs are composed of tissues.
What I didn't mention before was the four major types of tissues which make up
the organs of our body muscle tissues and the function of muscle tissues is to
do work to in order to do work,
uh,
nervous tissue.
And the function of nervous tissue is to communicate right using a electrical
impulses primarily to communicate epithelial tissues,
which form linings in the body.
So your skin is an epithelium tissue.
The lining of your gut is an epithelial tissue.
The linings of all the glands in your body,
like the pancreas are epithelial tissues and connective tissues which,
uh,
are responsible for holding all these things together into one unit.
Yeah.
So all cells are the same.
And I say that because any cell within you or within me is the same in many
respects,
right?
It has a cell membrane.
If I looked inside,
it has the same kinds of components inside.
Um,
it has the same DNA inside the nucleus.
Yeah.
But let's take a step back and ask,
are all kinds of cells really the same?
And start by talking about two cells that I know,
you know,
are quite different cells that I took from a human and sells that I,
that are in a bacterium,
right?
So what's,
what are the differences between a bacterial cell and a human cell?
Okay.
What are some of the differences between the bacterial cell and a human cell?
Yeah,
the bacterium doesn't have a nucleus and in fact,
they don't have very well formed a organelles in general.
Uh,
human cells have well-described organelles inside of them.
And,
and you took biology in high school.
You learn the names of these organelles and their principal functions,
the nucleus,
the endoplasmic reticulum,
the Golgi apparatus,
Mitochondria,
lysosomes.
So there's those things are all reviewed in the chapter in the book.
I'm not going to talk about them in detail,
but please look at that.
Uh,
to remind yourself of those kinds of specialized sub cellular units,
which are present in cells,
in humans,
but not present in bacteria.
Now,
why aren't they present in bacteria?
Okay,
why don't,
why don't bacteria need a distinct nucleus?
And that's necessary in a,
uh,
in a human cell.
Yeah.
Or what else is different about,
about human cells and bacteria other than these formed organelles?
Human cells don't have a cell wall,
but,
um,
most bacteria do.
There are different kinds of a cell walls in bacteria,
but they have a rigid cell wall and our,
and our cells don't have a rigid cell.
While we have a fluid lipid like cell wall.
Why,
why is that the case?
Well,
you can think about the cell wall of a bacterium as its skeleton,
right?
It's what protects it from the mechanical forces that are out in the world.
We have other ways of protecting.
Many of our cells are inside our body protected by,
uh,
by specialized cells,
of our skeletal system.
And so they don't need that kind of mechanical strength.
Right?
Well,
another important difference between human cells and bacterial cells as their
size.
Bacterial cells are small one to two microns in diameter.
And this shows a picture of a,
of a common,
a bacterium called [inaudible].
And this is,
this is a bacterium that's a,
uh,
normally present in,
in humans.
It colonizes all of our intestinal systems.
Uh,
and so it's,
it's a,
it's a common,
it's a common bacterium and most strains of e coli are not harmful to people.
In fact,
they provide us with some beneficial properties.
Um,
a human cell shown here on the,
on the opposite side has these formed organelles that I talked about a minute
ago.
Mitochondria,
Golgi endoplasmic reticulum nucleus.
It's encased within a membrane,
a cell membrane,
which we talked about the structure of and um,
and it's much larger than a bacterium.
It's 10 to 30 microns,
let's say instead of one to two microns.
So almost 10 times bigger.
One of the reasons why,
um,
why human cells have compartment is because,
uh,
their functions are segregated into regions,
right?
The nucleus contains all the DNA.
And so the early stages of gene expression transcription happen inside the
nucleus where all the DNA is,
right?
And one of the reasons why you would want to segregate things into certain
regions is that molecules have to move in order to accomplish these things,
right?
Molecules have to move from one place to another and in general,
inside of the cell,
molecules move by a process called diffusion.
They move from regions of high concentration to regions of low concentration by
this natural flow down a concentration gradient and movement down.
A concentration gradient occurs fairly rapidly over short distances like um,
like a micron or so like the size of a bacterium.
Diffusion mixes things very well,
but as the size gets bigger,
defect diffusion becomes very slow.
Yeah,
right.
And you're familiar with this.
If I had,
if I had a jar of acetone or some kind of a volatile liquid,
let's say I have perfume,
I have a jar of perfume and I sit up here.
If the room was still,
the molecules of perfume would diffuse out of this jar and they'd start moving
through the room and those of you in the first row would smell it within a few
minutes.
Sometime later you'd smell it one row back.
Sometime later.
And the farther away you get,
the longer it takes.
But because of the physics of diffusion,
it doesn't go linearly with distance.
That is,
it doesn't take one second to go the first and then two seconds to go.
The second three seconds to go to third.
It varies with the square of distance.
So it goes in order to go twice as far takes four times as long.
And these details aren't important.
It is described in your book,
but then the thing that is important to know is that diffusion occurs fast over
short distances.
But because of the physics of diffusion,
it occurs slowly over longer distances.
And because of that,
you can't count on molecules moving rapidly over the size of a cell that's 10 to
30 microns in diameter.
Because of that,
in order to have efficient function,
then you group all the like activities together,
right?
That's why that's,
that's one way of thinking why animal cells have cells from animals and humans
have a sub cellular compartments.
Another thing that's different about a human cells and um,
and animal human cells and bacterial cells is that many bacterial cells can
swim.
And can exist in suspension.
That means just suspended in a fluid.
In fact,
that's their preferred state is suspended in a fluid where nutrients are widely
available to them and where they can swim from one spot to another in order to
get the nutrients they need or in order to run away from toxic compounds.
Right?
And if you're a bacterium,
you're whole life is about swimming to nutrients and running away from things
that would kill you.
Right?
Human cells.
Most human cells don't function very well in suspension if you take cells from
my skin and disperse them and we will talk about ways to do that next time.
And you tried to maintain them in a beaker.
Even if that beaker had all the nutrients that skin cells needed,
they wouldn't survive very well in solution.
They tend to need to be stuck to a surface in order to survive.
And that's what this picture on the bottom shows you.
Here it's,
it's a,
it's a picture of cells actually a growing and moving in cell culture.
This is a cell from connective tissue called a fiber fiberblast.
And instead of being round like this cartoon of a cell,
uh,
when you have the selling culture in a,
in a plastic or a glass dish,
it tends to stick to the dish and spread out.
So it looks much more like a,
like a pancake,
a funny shaped pancake,
uh,
but at pancake than a sphere,
what,
and this property of cells in culture is called anchorage dependence,
that the cell needs to be anchored to a surface in order to function properly.
That's another difference between,
uh,
between human cells and bacteria.
Now what does that have to do with the life of a cell inside the body?
It's this,
this picture on the bottom shows the cell stuck to plastic.
Certainly that's not what it's like when it's inside the body.
While it's true that it's not stuck to plastic,
but it is stuck to other materials and the other materials that it stuck to
include other cells that surround it.
And this complex,
um,
matrix which surrounds all of the cells in our body called extracellular matrix.
And I'll get to that in just a few moments.
So in some senses,
most of the cells in our body are stuck to a surface.
They're stuck to his surface that's provided by the environment that's around
them,
right?
They're not swimming free in solution.
Well,
you know,
that cells in our body can reproduce and most of you have probably at some point
or another,
uh,
learned about the cell cycle or the process of a cell going from,
being a single cell to being,
uh,
two cells and,
um,
that's shown schematically here.
Let me talk about the bottom,
uh,
diagram first,
which shows the process of my tosas and my ptosis is an orderly sequence of
events by which one parent's cell becomes two daughter cells.
And several things happened during my tosas.
First,
when a cell enters the process of my Tosas,
it already has twice.
It's the DNA that it needs,
right?
So before a cell enters might ptosis,
it has to have synthesized its DNA.
So it has two copies of all of its chromosomes.
Uh,
so what happens during my tosas is that the cell is able to separate this double
set of chromosomes into two sets.
Okay.
And that happens,
uh,
in,
in a way that's shown in this cartoon here.
It's separates those,
uh,
duplicated chromosomes to two sides of the cell,
physically separates them.
And the sale itself pinches off to form,
uh,
to,
new cells where if this happens,
it correctly,
uh,
each of the new cells has exactly the same composition as the,
as the,
as the parent sl.
Okay.
Well,
my ptosis is one event that happens during this larger event called the cell
cycle.
It's usually shown like a clock is shown here where a time zero,
which is at the,
here is right at the end of my tosas where you have two new cells that are
formed.
So if I followed one of them,
it is in a phase that's called a g one first.
And this is a resting phase before it enters the process of synthesizing new DNA
in preparation for another round of mytosis.
A G two is a phase that indicates the gap between when DNA synthesis occurs and
when the next mitotic event occurs.
Right?
And so if sales were actively proliferating,
that is,
you had a population of cells that are actively PR proliferating.
They would be going through continuous rounds of the cell cycle,
new cells or form.
They weighed a bit,
they synthesize DNA,
they weighed a bit,
they divide and on and on and on.
Uh,
well not all of the cells in your body are dividing at any one time,
right?
Not all the cells are dividing.
In fact,
cells in your brain don't proliferate it.
All right?
Some small subsets do,
but most of the cells in your brain don't proliferate.
And that's because they get trapped at one portion of the cell cycle.
They get arrested in the g one phase,
for example,
and they never progressed through to the s phase where they synthesize DNA,
right?
So cells can stop in their lifetime at some point in the sales cycle and persist
for long periods of time.
Well,
this process of cell proliferation or cell division is,
um,
is of course very important during development of an embryo and during
development of the embryo.
It goes from being a single cell,
the fertilized egg to being a multicellular organism,
uh,
with the,
with billions of cells in it.
And those billions of cells come from successive rounds of cell division.
Now
I said before that all cells are the same.
And when I talked about,
uh,
my Tosas,
I talked about cells making a perfect copies of each other.
So each parent's cell becoming two daughter cells that are the same.
And so if,
uh,
if that was all that was happening,
that an embryo would just be many,
many cells that are all identical and you know,
that's not the case,
right?
So cells start to change and they change in complex ways so that eventually
when,
uh,
when a fetus is born,
it has some cells that make up its brain.
Some that make up the,
some that make up the liver and the skin and all those cells are different in
important ways.
Okay.
Well,
I'm going to talk next week or next time on Thursday about the processes that
lead to differences between cells.
Yeah.
The general word for that process of making differences between cells is
differentiation.
Okay.
When cells become
okay,
more like cells of the mature brain,
they're said to differentiate into brain cells.
When they become more like the liver,
they differentiate into liver cells.
And so we're going to talk about that process,
uh,
more,
next time.
What I want you to,
uh,
remember,
now is that abundant cell proliferation takes place during development.
Yeah.
All of the cells that are reproduced during development are the same in certain
ways.
They contain the same DNA.
They're all progeny of the same fertilized egg,
but differences are acquired within specific cell populations during the process
of development.
Okay.
Some of those differences in cells are obvious if you look at the cells in an
adult organism.
And in fact,
some cells are very different from the cells that are,
uh,
are proliferating early in development.
And one example of a very different sell is a red cell or red blood cell.
These are the cells that,
uh,
that give blood.
It's red color.
They make up about a 45 to 50% of the volume of blood is red cells.
And they're red because they contain a,
a special protein called hemoglobin,
which is very concentrated inside the cell.
And Hemoglobin as you know,
is an oxygen carrier.
And so red blood cells concentrated bags of hemoglobin which circulate in your
blood and they carry oxygen.
Well.
Um,
it was not very hard for me to draw this red blood cell here cause it's just an
oval.
And one reason I draw like an oval is that that's basically what it looks like
if you look at it.
And one of the most obvious things about our red blood cells,
it doesn't have a nucleus,
it has no a nucleus.
And so red blood cells are terminally differentiated cells.
They have become as different as they can be.
In fact,
they're no longer capable of reproducing a,
all they can do is exist as red blood cells and then die.
Right.
So they've lost one of the essential characteristics of the cells that are the
same that I talked about earlier.
Yeah.
That's just an example of a cell that in it's very mature or differentiated form
is quite different from other cells inside the body.
On the other side of this diagram,
I show a picture of a neuron.
Um,
this is just an example of what a neuron might look like.
Here's the nucleus in the middle of the cell body.
And what if you looked at a picture of a variety of different cells that were
isolated from adult organisms.
You would recognize this immediately as a neuron or something that's like a
neuron because of the many small thin projections that come out of the body of
the cell.
And neurons have these projections because one important property or one
important function of neurons is to communicate with each other.
And the way that they communicate with each other is by physically touching each
other.
And the way that they connect across distances is by having these processes that
extend from one place to another.
So like many cells,
uh,
in neurons,
the shape of the cell is intimately related to its function within the organism.
And that's obvious when you look at neurons.
And it will be obvious when we look at other kinds of cells as well.
Because of this,
often a biologist can discriminate between different kinds of cells that they
see in a section of a tissue,
for example,
uh,
merely by its shape
and the characteristics that it has.
And so one could easily,
for example,
differentiate between a red cell and a neuron.
But as skilled biologist who's looked at many,
many different sales could differentiate between different types of neurons,
maybe by the different branching patterns that these processes had,
or how many processes were on a different kind of neuron.
You'd be able to tell something about its function and probably something about
where it came from.
And you might be able to tell just by looking at it,
what was,
if there was a disease,
what was wrong with it?
And Inter in between these two pictures,
I show a picture of a fiberblast fibroblasts are specialized cells that exist in
connective tissues.
So the connective tissue was one of those four main types of tissue.
They're supporting material,
supporting tissues that surround,
um,
other cells in the body and give the cell and give the body much of its
mechanical property.
One of the important functions of a fiberblast is to,
uh,
is to allow for healing of wounds.
And this shows a fibroblasts that is very stretched out.
And remember when I showed you that picture of cells attached to plastic a few
minutes ago,
I said those were fibroblasts that were growing on a culture dish.
If,
um,
if I looked within the skin,
one of the lower layers of your skin,
the connective tissue layer,
you'd find many fiberblast there.
And they're just waiting in a more rounded shape than this just waiting,
uh,
to do their job.
And their job begins.
If you happen to cut yourself for example,
or you get a wound and when you get a wound,
several things start to happen first,
hopefully your blood clots.
And so that stops you from dying from loss of blood there.
But,
um,
but your body tries to heal this wound that's created.
And one of the first steps in that healing is that fiber blast.
Like this cell crawl into this space that's created by the wound and they grab a
hold of both sides of the wound and contract and try to pull it together.
To do that,
they have to be able to stretch out and they have to be able to pull.
And if you look at this picture of this fiberblast,
you can imagine that it's firmly stuck up here.
It's firmly adherent to the surface here.
It's firmly adherent at the back here and in between it's trying to pull these
ends closer together.
You can imagine that that's what it's doing.
And in fact,
that's one of the functions of fibroblasts.
So this is another example of,
uh,
of,
of how the shape of a cell can tell you something about its function,
how you can discriminate between different cells by looking at how they,
uh,
how they look in,
in,
uh,
in their native environment.
So humans are collections of cells.
All cells are the same in important ways,
but cells acquire differences during development.
And so we are a collections of billions of cells.
What holds us together so that when I leave the room,
uh,
most of my sales go with me.
What holds all these cells that are doing different things together?
Well,
one thing that holds the cells together is that they're able to adhere to each
other.
That cells that form tissues often have junctions,
uh,
that,
that hold them together so that they don't fall apart and they,
and they exist as a solid piece of tissue.
And so this diagram is supposed to,
supposed to make you think about the intestinal tract.
This tube that runs through our bodies and allows us to acquire nutrients from
the environment.
And uh,
this to this hollow tube,
which food passes through is made up of many,
many epithelial cells,
which directly abut one another and would be a flat sheet except that it's
rolled up into a tube,
right?
And it's this tube like structure,
which is made of many,
many epithelial cells all directly adjacent to each other is what separates the
outside world from our internal bodies,
right?
We take bits of the outside world like food and we swallow them,
And One can imagine that when they're inside this tube here,
there's still really outside the body,
right?
If the,
if the,
if it passed directly through the tube and nothing happened to it,
it would come out to the outside world.
Again,
there's a continuous path from the outside world,
right?
Right through the intestine.
That food only becomes part of us if it gets absorbed through the intestinal
wall.
That is,
if it can be absorbed through this layer of epithelium,
right?
So what happens in the intestine is that food gets broken down into constituent
molecules.
Some of those molecules are absorbed into our bodies.
They become part of us and the rest get we would get rid of and they remained
part of the outside world,
right?
So it's these cells that are sitting at the surface here that are responsible
for determining what becomes part of us and what stays outside.
And one of the ways they can do this is that there's no space in between these
cells.
This cell can only be an effective barrier
if there's no way to get past it,
right?
And so cells of the epithelium are actually welded to one another through these
junctions called tight junctions.
And these junctions,
these red dots here actually made up of proteins.
Some are synthesized by one cell summer synthesize by each other and they lock
together to form a very
tight barrier,
uh,
to form a tight junction between the two cells.
And because of that,
if,
uh,
if I eat something that's rich in glucose,
so it has lots of sugar molecules that sugar molecules can't pass between the
cells,
that's how tight the junctions are.
Not even a small molecule like glucose can pass between them.
In order for glucose to enter our body,
it has to go through the cells in order for it to get inside the cells and go
through them.
There have to be transporters which specifically allow glucose to pass into the
cell and then out into our body.
Right?
So there's a couple of features of cellular physiology,
which are shown here.
One is that cells form tissues that are mechanically intact mechanically,
they have mechanical integrity because they,
uh,
they can adhere to one another.
Yeah.
And the other is that this kind of adherence gives the tissue a property that's
useful.
In this case,
the property is,
it can serve as a barrier to,
uh,
to,
nutrients from entering our body.
Yeah.
The other reason why cell state together is that they're surrounded by a matrix,
this called extra cellular matrix and that Matrix has properties,
um,
that um,
vary in different locations in the body,
but basically it's a highly hydrated or water rich Gel.
And so,
uh,
you know what Jello is?
Everybody knows what Jello is,
right?
Uh,
it's usually colored because there's food dye in it,
uh,
but it wouldn't be colored in.
It's natural state.
Jello is a hydrated solution of Collagen and it contains a lot of water.
Uh,
piece of Jello,
uh,
has probably 99% water in it,
but it has a shape,
right?
If you make Jello,
um,
and you,
you make it right then once it's set or jelled,
it has mechanical properties.
You,
if you made it in a cup and you tried to pour it out,
it was still have the shape of the cup when it came out.
And because of this,
my mother used to make Jello that had fruit suspended in it,
right?
And the,
and the fruit doesn't sink to the bottom like you'd expect it to sync through
water,
but it stays suspended inside.
Anybody's mother make Jello with fruit in it.
So that's how cells exist in extracellular matrix.
Extracellular matrix in most tissues is,
is abundant in Collagen and other proteins like Collagen.
This collagen is highly hydrated.
It forms a Gel that has water properties,
but it also has solid properties.
Right.
We'll talk about exactly what a gel is later when we talk about biomechanics and
cells are suspended within it and the extra cellular matrix or the college in
jail gives the tissue integrity and in part determines its mechanical
properties.
Do you have a question?
So where does the college and come from?
The college and is excluded by cells themselves.
So the matrix is made by cells.
In fact,
fibroblasts,
which I talked about before,
are very good producers of Collagen and they produce the Collagen Matrix within
which they live
and some cells digest Collagen.
And so what,
what ex,
what extra cellular matrix you have in any particular tissue?
Is there,
because there's a balance between it being produced by one kind of cell and
digested by another and you're in this sort of state of dynamic equilibrium.
Okay,
I'm going to stop there and we'll continue on Thursday.